pft pm podcast pre-draft edition as we
get closer and closer to the start of
selection process on thursday night and
joining us now
on behalf of old spice it's alabama
receiver henry rugs old spice is
donating 320 000 to united way on behalf
of henry ruggs and rookies from all 32
teams to help young players begin their
charitable efforts as they join the
league fans can make their own
contributions
during the nfl's three-day draft-a-thon
virtual fundraiser by visiting nfl.com
relief henry ruggs joining us again 4.27
seconds in the 40
and uh welcome
uh to the pft pm podcast where henry
how's everything going
it's going good thank you for having me
when did you realize you were really
really fast how old were you and what
was the circumstance
um
well
i started off racing my mom just you
know just like in the street or went to
the car you know when we were going to
grocery stores but i probably realized
that i was one of the fastest guys when
i was about
9 or 10 when i first played football you
know in little league i used to take i
should take crazy angles to get away
from tactless i never did
anything i would always just run around
because i was scared to get hit
so
you know i never got touched and that
was that was when i started to realize i
was one of the fastest guys
and once you knew you were fast did you
then consciously spend time working to
get as fast as you possibly can be and
if so what did you do to get as fast as
you could be oh definitely once i once i
realized you know that i had that
ability in my legs then i kind of just
hammered on my legs from there you know
i used to do
um all kind of little crazy things you
know if i'm standing still i'm doing
calf raises if um if i'm just sitting
still or something i'll probably just
you know do some bodyweight squats or
something or just just run for for no
reason i always did anything just to you
know build strength in my legs and just
run around all day
beyond the fact that you are
ridiculously fast henry what do you
think your best attribute is on a
football field oh of course we're gonna
go with speed
other than that
other than that i mean i feel like i
have
you know i have ability in every
category so other than speed you know i
definitely feel like i have i have
pretty good hands
we hear so much about the sec and so
much about alabama what a great program
it is nick saban with his nfl
connections what do you think
prepared you the most for the nfl
playing your college career at alabama
um
the biggest thing being a competition
that's probably that's probably one
thing that that that fuels everybody you
know from the university of alabama you
know the competition there is is very
stiff and you're practicing with some of
the best every day so that's that's one
thing that's going to make you you know
a better competitor it's definitely
going to make you go hard every day and
you're never going to get complacent
because at any time you know you have
another guy just like you coming right
behind
you could have been uh come back to
alabama for one more season henry how
close of a decision was it for you and
how did you go about
making that final call to enter the
draft when you when you had one more
year of eligibility
um it was definitely a a decision that
came down to the came down to the wire i
was i was really i was really considered
strongly considering going back and um
you know decision ultimately came down
to my younger brother just telling me
you know my brothers are or my my
lifeline you know my backbones you know
the people that mean the most to me and
my younger brother just told me that
that i should take advantage of the
opportunity and you know he was just
saying that he
he was good on everything you know on
his hand and he just wanted me to you
know go ahead and go into the draft
you know when when you're uh
older than i am now like 50 years from
now and you're sitting in a rocking
chair like i am now and henry ruggs the
fifth wants to hear a story from you
about nick saban what's the first story
that you're going to tell when it's time
to tell your grandson about nick staton
i'm definitely going to tell him that
that he could cover me you know he
always felt like he was the
the top db you know in the world and
whenever we would go for drill to drill
i would always just run by and we'll do
this thing you know i try to cut them
off like as if i'm stacking them you
know as running the route stacking them
getting in front of him and he would
always try to cut me off like he's
pushing me toward the sideline
and you know i guess he got tired of
beating me so he kind of took a cheap
shot one day
and
you know ran over to the drill and as
soon as he got to the drill he turned
and asked for you know like where's rug
said you know why's russ not jail he's
taking you know is he taking practice
off today or something like that so you
know that's that's one of my favorite
stories and one that i'm definitely
going to
you know he he does have that reputation
for being a kind of a hard ass but also
i hear from a lot of players that he's
funny um from the perspective of the
players there's got to be somebody on
the team that would do a great nick
saban impersonation who on the roster
while you were there was the one who
would do that nick saban impression just
kind of lighten the mood and poke fun at
them a little bit
oh man we had um we had a couple guys
you know but honestly the best guy was
not was not on the team it was uh
it was uh
kothy's there robbie zell he uh he was a
former receiver so you know he i feel
like he does the best impression so none
of the none of the guys on the team
could could do the impression that he
did
there's been a lot of talk about your
quarterback tuatanga by lower recently
nick saban came out and said hey anybody
that passes on this guy is making a huge
mistake make your pitch on behalf of
your quarterback tuatanga by law as to
why teams should take him as early as
they can in the draft
i mean definitely i mean i'm i i bad
coach 100 on that you know if you if you
miss out on him you definitely missing
out on a guy that's gonna make make your
team better make your organization
better and a guy that's gonna come out
and and do what he has to do he's a he's
a fierce relentless competitor you know
he always even though he does have you
know the injury history he always came
back you know ten times better and came
back and you know made his impact you
know right right away you know he played
he played hurt he did you know he did
all kind of thing but he always made the
team better he he's a great competitor
and a great leader at the same time but
also he's a great just a great guy you
know
you make a great case for two and now
henry ruggs make the case for henry
ruggs to be drafted as high as possible
oh hitman rose is definitely i mean he's
a goddess that's going to do everything
you know everything that he needs to do
he's a guy you can put anyone on the
field at any time he's definitely going
to be there
and produce and give you 110
i mean regardless of regardless of the
situation it's no longer too big for
your roads
henry i don't know how much you pay
attention to the rumors that are
floating around out there now can make
you dizzy if you look at too much of it
but our friend peter king had a rumor
yesterday that the chiefs
are thinking about trying to move up in
round one they're currently at number
32. they want to move up to try to get
you what's your reaction when you hear
that
oh man that's uh that's that's crazy but
you know if i was if i was blessed with
that opportunity to go you know to go up
there with that team and you know
showcase my talents with around that the
caliber of talent and it'll be
it'll be unreal you know i was actually
um you know talking to miko yesterday
and was just having a conversation and
he even mentioned it and i was just like
bro that would be scary
this pandemic has made the pre-draft
process so different than it otherwise
would be you'd have been taking visits
you'd have private workouts it would
have been much more involved
now instead it's a lot of conversations
like this what teams have you spoken to
in a setting like this with video
conference um
man i spoke with numerous teams from
from las vegas to philadelphia denver um
uh detroit uh it's it's been some of
everybody you know it's been it's been
everywhere i get you know i just get
random calls you know from from time to
time whenever i'm you know whenever i'm
not doing anything you know guys will
text me and just tell me to call it so
they can just have a quick conversation
and
you know it's been it's been a couple
teams you know just constantly
who is it that you've heard from
constantly who you heard from the most
um
i say probably between
between
vegas vegas denver and san francisco
do you have any kind of a friendly bet
with jerry judy as to who goes first
oh no i mean we haven't we haven't
really really said too much about that
you know we both
we both feel like we're we're guys that
that should be taking high in the job
you know regardless of where we go we
know we're going to make the best of it
and that's that's pretty much the
message that we that we try to harden
each other regardless of
of anything you know we're competing for
for our job in the far spot but you know
at the same time we're still brothers we
we had our time you know and now it's
time for us to work together just in
different areas
who is it that when you were a young
football player you looked up to you
idolized you wanted to emulate
oh man um
i mean of course when everybody was
younger around my generation everybody
wanted to be randy moss
and and you know i see you where number
number 11. uh is there any specific
reason why you had number 11 at alabama
um well one because my high school
number six was to was to um
but you know my big it's a funny story
behind number 11. you know i always felt
like you know even even through school i
always wanted to wear number one but you
know i was a guy that that felt like
number one was overrated because
everybody wanted to be number one and
if you were number one you had to be
that guy so you had to be doing
you know where i'm from if you had no
more you got to be playing both sides of
the ball you got to be that you know the
star of the team you know the leader
always wore number one and i felt like
it was just an overrated number but i
always wanted to wear it so i felt like
if i get two ones then you know people
would people would overlook me but i
could still be that guy and i'm still
number one i just got two of them
you mentioned randy moss have you had a
chance to ever meet him talk to him get
any advice from him
yeah the crazy thing is you know i was
down in the temple working out you know
for the combine and he actually came
down there and worked on work with us
hands-on so that was that was a crazy
experience and and we kind of you know
we kind of developed a relationship and
he was telling me some things and i
definitely you know definitely keep it
in the back of my mind whenever i'm
doing anything and he just i mean he
helped me build build even more
confidence with some things that he told
me
did you see him run does he still have
it
he still got a little bit you know he
he get kind of old you know he'd be out
there trying to throw to us and his arm
and give out you know so
so he he definitely you know getting
getting of age but he still he still got
a up little
it is amazing when you see the
highlights of what he did as a rookie in
the nfl he was unstoppable and henry we
hope the same thing happens for you
we're looking forward to seeing where
you land on thursday night maybe it'll
be the cheapest maybe it would be
somebody else but we appreciate your
time congratulations on your success and
all the best moving forward
thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports